who's to say she can't have both i don't
know yeah it's a bit frustrating it's uh
it's a bad timing i'm playing
gabrielle's flag hard all the way home
don't worry about it that's so invested
personally in fake emily so like i don't
like
crazy
the emily in paris season two finale
blew my mind and it was a bit of deja vu
lily when you discovered that when emily
goes to professor love again to
gabrielle and realizes that he's moving
in with comey what was your reaction oh
my god i remember reading that going
wait come on she finally works up the
courage to say something and then of
course comey's behind the door i just
love the fact that comey had her little
earpods on so that's how it spoils it
because she hears her and then she turns
around so innocently and she's like oh i
didn't see you there but it's like
actually the perfect representation of i
think cami's character this season
because there's so many nuanced moments
when comey playing kemi is so brilliant
at toeing that fine line of like is she
or isn't she does she know does she not
know is she being mean is she being nice
you know and so the idea that that's how
emily finds out and is so jarred by it i
just found to be just so emily and the
situation and i was like devastated for
her lucas what was your reaction when
you first read the script you know they
kind of write the script as we as we
should so we got the last episode really
at the last moment it's an entire season
of him trying to actually he knows what
he wants he knows he wants to be with
emily it's an entire season of rejection
so i wasn't surprised that at the end he
ends up falling with the only person
that actually wants him and loves him
but yeah it's a bit frustrating it's uh
it's a bad timing which is kind of life
was what life is all about wow this is
just to see you around then
you know i feel like there's this sort
of interesting dynamic between emily
comey and
gabrielle
and i feel like you know emily at the
end of season one kind of crossed the
line with comey and i think he spent a
lot of season two trying to make amends
for that and make up for that and do the
right thing and i think in a way comey
smartly plays emily in season two and
emily wasn't expecting it and i think by
the end of season two she decides you
know enough time has gone by she wants
to you know sort of express her true
feelings and because of the deal she
makes with comey she sort of let
gabrielle go you know comey did not in a
way hold up her end of the bargain no
there's something else behind this i
just don't know yet what it is comey had
a lot of layers to her this season how
are you feeling about her journey and
let's be real shouldn't we all just be
mad at gabrielle
yeah that's quite the girl's code to be
mad at the men and not the girlfriends
yeah i'm so grateful that i get more
storyline and that camille is becoming
such a more complex and interesting
character than in season one also the
businesswoman side of it and her
relationship with emily she doesn't want
to lose her she wants to keep her she
wants to keep her friendship with her
but also as a person she's trying to
figure it out how to react to this new
because it's it's very hurtful obviously
but the most important thing is emily is
trying to fix
things
and that's why i'm not mad i guess no
drama i feel like you know gabriel has
been very nice and polite and accepting
a lot and not very owning up to his
decisions you know it's just like living
things and floating without really
caring about who he hurts i think he
knows a bit but it doesn't really own up
to that decision i feel like i would
love to see him you know owning up to
his actions and going to something a bit
in darker corners of his uh soul heart
mind and i don't know he's always so
clean and polite i just want to see him
i just want to mess him up a bit paris
from this angle at night and you got me
that cooper lucian i need to give you
major props because i'm not gonna lie i
thought i was gonna be a gabrielle
shipper forever but alfie gave him a run
for his money in season two
absolute gabrielle i'm still gabrielle
i'm still gabrielle over here i'm flying
gabrielle's flag hard all the way home
don't worry about it honestly i was the
new kid at school coming in the second
season and yeah alfie gets to ruffle
emily in a different kind of way he gets
to break it down yeah it just just just
gets a bit a bit more naughty with that
you know like they get to drunk and have
some fun and it just opens up a
different size family so i think uh yeah
alfie's
cool oh cooper m having someone who's an
antagonist a family who doesn't buy into
the hype of paris and it's it's just
like i've always loved uh england and
the humor and sarcasm and i think it's
so refreshing to have that kind of
perspective and i'm pretty sure you know
parisians and haters from season one are
gonna love healthy because that's a bit
of truth you know we needed a bit of
truth everything was just like bubbly
and paris paris paris and it's nice to
have like another angle you need to
decide what you want and not what's
going to make everyone else happy who do
you think fits best with emily which
relationship are you currently rooting
for i don't know
i don't know there's also the option of
just like not picking either that's not
fun isn't it
she's like yeah no i don't know i that's
really hard i think that honestly like
kami's moved in this is what she's been
wanting this whole time i think she i i
would say emily take a beat this is
toxic this is back and forth
stop with the like give them some space
yeah and let's revisit it and then like
alfie's awesome like try this i would
say
also just take a trip to london and see
what you feel if you vibe with alfie
great if not you've taken a trip to
london and because you haven't seen his
life what if he's yeah what if it's not
you didn't like his apartment yeah yeah
yeah maybe it's not gonna work out well
i just got so invested personally in
fake emily so like i don't like crazy no
that's really hard
that's really hard i don't know i think
i think she should stay single she'll
have
less third guy has to come in because i
mean how can we choose between lucas and
luciano it's like impossible
i've made my decision we gotta talk
about that epic season two cliffhanger
it was so good but so frustrating
lily what do you think emily is going to
do i know you don't know i genuinely
don't know and we keep being like so
when am i going to find out like are we
going to find out do we get to go to
season three like what happens we really
want to know we want to know i mean
let's be real i think emily would love a
trip to london i think that would be
really fun but honestly it's a really
quick eurostar trip who's to say she
can't have both i don't know i mean
we'll have to see i think you know i
think she's also very honored and
surprised that sylvie wants her to come
with her to her job to the new business
so i don't know can't wait
i'd say if i was an author i would write
that she goes to london and she's really
disappointed with alfie and she has to
come back i don't think i can top that
that's a good one we don't know anything
you know darren is pretty private about
this i don't think he even knows himself
he likes to tangle everything before he
goes on vacation to be sure that when he
comes back for next season he has a
massive headache to deal with that's his
problem i don't want to get into that as
writers i mean i feel like we write
ourselves you know to the cliff's edge
and just about often there's just and i
know we have you know we sort of like
game it out a little bit there's a
number of different ways that things can
go and i always feel that we sort of
take those ideas of how things can sort
of play out and then try to even like
surprise ourselves i think emily has a
lot of interesting choices ahead of her
and i'm already desperate for season
three i know that that's a lot to put on
you right now but what is one aspect
should we get another season that you
would love to tackle next you know i
really love how emily gets more
assimilated into french culture and i
love seeing that sort of evolution and
transformation of somebody who's made
paris their home and how that changes
them and what we really haven't seen
except for madeleine we get it a little
bit it's how emily is in relation to
people that she's sort of like left
behind and how being an expatriate for a
longer period of time sort of changes
her own relationship with her home oh is
it for mom paul cooper could we see
emily's parents in the next possibly
sure i mean i i feel like
emily is this time in paris has turned
all her assumptions about who she is and
what her life's about sort of on their
head so i think that she has like so
many options open to her and i think
she's at a point where she can like take
a big risk if you're gonna do paris for
one year
for god's sake do it right